You guys ready to do this? Hahaha.  You might remember this guy.  This is Brian Brushwood with The Modern Rogue.  Links in the description so
you can go check out his channel
And we were back today testing out whether or not you can actually make a grenade with a coconut. [it's] cold. We're semi protected
We have a blast shield we got coconuts. That's what coconuts. Look like in, Texas
Hey, don't Judge, Texas by our coconuts everybody knows that moldy coconuts are a delicacy all right. So back when I was growing up
There's a movie called Swiss Family Robinson. Yeah, sure the Disney class it's a
1960s movie about a family they got shipwrecked on an island that got invaded by pirates in the way that they defended themselves was by
Making these coconut grenades and throwing over the edges
So they basically use black powder coconut shells and I imagine banana leaves to make the fuses and they made these improvised
explosives
So do they actually work the purpose of this experiment today is to find out whether or not you can actually
Use a coconut to make a grenade this isn't an experiment. We would recommend trying at home
That's why we're not trying it in my home. We're trying hip prints and we're not telling you
How we do it either?
These fuses have dried out overnight they become pretty stiff and rigid and we've done a couple of tests and they do look promising
They burn a little bit faster than we were expecting right? Oh, my gosh lightning fast. We're Gonna run
Now one thing that's a little bit unfortunate is most of the coconuts
We got were young and you can tell that because these ones are white now
He's black and white don't you look at the face of that coconut you can see two eyes and a mouth yep
Yep, now. I want you to just take that screwdriver and show us how difficult it is to burrow through the mouth
Oh jeez hahaha. I
Did not expect that man. I was thinking we need a drill or some nonsense
Now in contrast why don't you try poking that through one of the eyes? Oh, jesus not happening. Oh, really?
[oh], wow had no idea [-] see guys. I wouldn't lie to you coconut knowledge people. He says oh, I'm so sorry
I don't know what I did to deserve it so update guys
We've got our coconuts prepped and ready all we have to do now is stick in a fuse and light them off this one has
little
One has more this one is just right which one is going to make the biggest effect
What do you think little more or most put your comments down below and let us know before we try it you know it's so
Cold out here. My lips are frigid. Yeah, they're fridging up. So we rigged up the fuse here
We got the paper fuse that may or may not burn superfast and we've got sugar fuse taped to it as well
So this will give us quite a bit of burn time
We hope so we're starting off with the smallest charge we're going to set this thing and get behind our black shield and just see
How the [first] reaction goes I'm ready? I [filled] [it] [boss]. All right, so is this gonna work
This is our smallest charge, so it looks like this thing off and see how it does
Okay, I'm glad we have a shield that thing ricocheted and like just do I hit my face. I'm amazed
Wow
Look at that
That is full-on
Shrivel I saw a pieces flying probably at least a good 20 feet there
You know what I'm starting to think that there's some viability to the whole coconut grenade idea
[oh] yeah, no, I wouldn't want to be standing in the way of one wow let's check out the damage
Where's the coconut [it's] completely vaporized so your thoughts and impressions on that, Mr.. [Brushwood]. I was like comfortable with those projectiles
Now the next one has twice as much of the charge this one did so is it gonna be a bigger explosion or is it
going less of an explosion
Coconut grenade number two let's have at it. [alright]. I'm ready to do the [honours]
Good life here. He goes
oh
Wow, I mean that's looking more and more like a real grenade man dude
You know what my impression is like we'd probably use more powder than necessary
Yeah, because like there's so much still left behind but the power that that shell blast out with was was really preston
So I don't know where all the shrapnel win this one flew about 20 feet away smells like toasted coconut
Still chewy tribe. Oh is it yeah? [oh] there's still parts all we saw spits out butter in there
I wonder if that's because like it's a little bit too moist, so I didn't burn completely who?
tastes like coconut
So our next one actually has double that amount of power
We call this one big bertha. Yeah, we call this one Brian hides behind the blast shield tell me how it goes
It's gone. Oh
Dude, I felt the repercussion [for] that. That was like an electric shock. It was like a thunderclap right in front of us
whoa
Is that [amazing] it would have been deadly? Oh, you're right there
That's that's ripping arm off right there the shrapnel like flies out completely horizontal
Yeah, I know. It's none of this john t up it comes and down and falls
This is just like out of my way. You're killing people okay? [so] yes bigger is better bigger is bigger
Well guys, that's all we were able to find in five minutes of searching so check it out guys coconut grenades totally viable
[I] think so, so you're stranded on a deserted island battling pirates it might be a good option [to] yeah
You could just raid your cannons for the powder you can use banana leaves to make the fuses use the coconuts
[I] don't know how you make a blast shield up king of random. You're an agent of Chaos
Super cool hanging out with you guys today [too] big. Thanks to you Brian brushwood. Yeah
man join us over at the Modern Rogue Channel
We're doing all kinds of stuff like this
So I got his links in the description below if you like the stuff we're doing here
You're probably gonna like the stuff that he's doing over there as well, so go check [him] out [high] five yeah
There's good stuff, and high fives to you guys. We'll see you in the next experiment. Talk to you, then I?
Really can't I know it's cold family please
That's a good way to shred [coconut]. Oh yeah, it's just bits of coconut everywhere